der nächste bundeskanzler heißt armin
laschet
klar
dass sagt markus söder im tv interview
in der sendung bild live zweieinhalb
wochen vor der bundestagswahl steht die
union auf einem historischen tiefstand
bild chefredakteur julian reichelt will
wissen kriegt die union das ding noch
gedreht
ja wir müssen also wir müssen dieses
ding noch drehen wir müssen im trend
brechen allerdings das muss jetzt
passieren also wir können auf keinen
fall kampflos zu wählen wie am ende das
land nach links wandert so das muss
jetzt schon ordentlich gekämpft werden
so wie gestern im bundestag sogar die
kanzlerin hat sich ja massiv
eingeschaltet armin laschet kämpft seit
tagen sehr engagiert ich tue es
eigentlich seit monaten ich habe ja auch
darauf hingewiesen dass das dass ein
knappes rennen wird sie haben eben
gesagt
die lasche kämpft engagiert es ist in
den umfragewerten aber vollkommen klar
da kämpft derzeit der falsche 9%
zustimmungswerte gegen olaf scholz der
um die 30 prozent liegt die frage muss
einfach auch so kurz vor der wahl noch
mal gestellt wird ist da der falsche
kandidat im rennen
die entscheidung ist gefallen es ist
jetzt die zeit sich hinter den
kandidaten zu versammeln keine fragen zu
stellen was wäre was hätte sein können
sondern dass da überhaupt keinen sinn
jetzt die plakate sind ja geklebt die
wahlzettel sind gedruckt teilweise läuft
ja auch die briefwahl schon viele bürger
bürger haben jetzt abgegeben das heißt
es jetzt wirklich zu mobilisieren ich
stelle mich da zu 100 prozent dahinter
versuch auch ein beitrag zu bringen ich
glaube man muss neben der unterstützung
für den kandidaten die groß sein muss um
die geschlossen und auch überzeugend
sein muss braucht es umgekehrt aber auch
nochmal programmatischen aufschlag aber
er soll dann noch mal hand aufs herz die
csu läuft im moment unter die fünf
prozent grenze die csu ist moment
angewiesen auf direktmandate die union
insgesamt mit historisch schlechten
werten es fehlt teilweise dem kandidaten
selber hat man das gefühl der glaube
daran dass er das ding noch drehen kann
deswegen doch mal die konkrete frage
haben sie wenn jetzt jemand zu ihm käme
und sagen würde herr soda oder als
partei von markus machen sie es wären
sie dafür bereit
die frage stellt sich nicht da fragt
mich keiner sondern wir unterstützen
alle armin laschet und wenn sie jemand
fragen würde glauben sie dass sie die
umfragen sind der ja eindeutig armin
laschet liegt bei 9 prozent sie bei über
30 ist es nicht für normale menschen
kaum noch nachvollziehbar dass es da
nicht ein wechsel ein noch eine
auswechslung in letzter minute werden
wir beim fußball bleiben wollen geben
müsste
es hat keinen sinn darüber zu
diskutieren da sind die würfel gefallen
die cdu hat sich eindeutig entschieden
mit einer klaren mehrheit und wenn man
die letzten tage noch einmal gehört hat
von wolfgang schäuble an anderen ist
auch richtig komplette unterstützung
angela merkel für armin laschet auch
meine unterstützung und rückendeckung
hatte er es kommt jetzt auf den
kanzlerkandidaten an und er hatte in
anspruch darauf dass wir uns hinter ihn
stellen das tue ich so leidenschaftlich
wie sie sprechen wie oft denken sie
hätte man das mal bloß mir überlassen
nein das tue ich nicht ich habe damals
die wissen ist ja hundertfach diskutiert
worden ich hab' ich habe ein angebot
gemacht es ist ja auch die absolute
ausnahme des cs um überhaupt kandidaten
sein können das hat ja auch noch nie
geklappt ich habe ein angebot damals
gemacht es gab in der tat viel
zustimmung für mich zum teil über auch
überraschen wenn dieses land auf habe
mich an einige stehen sogar wirklich
bewegt wie viele menschen das gesagt
haben der bundesvorstand hat anders
entschieden und ich habe das ehrlich
gesagt sehr sehr akzeptiert sie sehen
ihren sitz im schönen bayern da ist es
wunderschön und aber ich bin trotzdem
mit der nächste bundeskanzler heißt
armin laschet
klar
[Musik]